alors aux dents c'est vrai que hier
gilles verdez notamment n'a pas été
tendre avec vous et c'est bien que vous
soyez là ce soir en même temps j'ai
gardé cet ordre avec qui ouais c'est
vrai exactement qu'avec fatou alors on
va pas se mentir au grand merci en tout
cas d'être là autant on dimitris est ce
que vous comprenez qu'ils aient pu être
choqués après il faut que vous nous
expliquiez parce que je crois qu ils ont
pris le sujet du mauvais côté
effectivement
en même temps c'est normal ça peut pas
ça peut paraître choquant mais
aujourd'hui d'un jour je pense que dans
tous les business que ce soit au de la
nuit ou d'autres il faut il faut quand
même savoir se renouveler et boîtes de
nuit avec une boule à facettes et un dj
dans les années 90 ça marche plus donc
il faut trouver des thématiques y en a
un qui était dans les années 80 donc
faut trouver des thématiques et c'est ce
que je m'évertue idée de mes vertus là
de faire depuis sur longtemps j'avais
les idées c'est cette idée de faire la
juge cette idée justement j'avais un
restaurant vers les champs elysées qui a
pas le gypsy motel d'accord et pendant
le comice a été très dur j'ai
honnêtement j'ai tout perdu là j'ai fait
rentrer des associés est en ce moment un
moment ça cartonnerait ça cartonne en ce
moment c'est le seul endroit où il
devrait être pendant cette période là en
face de nous il y avait un clochard qui
s'appelait thierry way et qu'on voyait
tous les jours j'ai joué tous les jours
ils galèrent avec moi j'avais les
huissiers j'étais pas bien on se parle
il m'a raconté sa vie on a échangé et
judy la prochaine affaire que je vais
faire bah écoute ça a raconté notre
galère et une autre galère c'était ça
donc tu si donc j'écris j'ai décidé de
créer la crise
on a des gilet jaune en serveur on a des
feymen au bar on a ça s'est passé pas de
syrie parce que justement 15 une semaine
avant l'ouverture j'essaie de le
retrouver je passe devant il est pas
lâché mais qu'est-ce qui fait pour lui
il est pas là son collègue qui vend les
marrons m'a dit qu'il était parti parce
qu'il faisait trop froid à paris jetez
plus d'un alors que j'avais une place
pour lui parce que mon côté le salarié
père qui le regarde on a compté le
salarié déjà d'une part d'autre part il
dormait dans le club le matin donc il
était à l'abri d'autre part les autres
en plus il prenait des tips des gens et
parce qu'il faisait la manche alors
qu'il gagne bien sa vie mais il va
revenir on attend on l'attend vraiment
et donc d'ailleurs vous êtes très vive
bravo parce que on a fait même pas une
soirée c'était la soirée un peu test on
a ouvert mercredi dès le jeudi on était
déjà sur les réseaux en mode donc
alors et on a nos chauffeurs de salle
qui ne parle pas français
quand tu n'envoies les applaudissements
l'important web avec quelqu'un que j'ai
la tête ça ouais ok
et donc là c'est un ami c'est roger donc
on voulait voir en situation comment les
clients allaient réagir justement et
voir comment ça se passe et si c'était
pas trop hardcore voilà donc il ya un
ami acteur et un peu foufou d'air et
donc
et donc on s'était mis dans cette
situation donc c'est bien en fait ça
c'était juste pour la campagne de promo
pour les réseaux où il ya vraiment un
nom veut vraiment faire tirer c'est pas
nous c'est devenu un peu un copain et
j'ai envie qu'ils qu'il était d'accord
il était d'accord pour que ça soit par
terre avec ses cartons à qu'ils soient
laddh qui soit dans le club dont il
vendra déçu c'est des petites rues mais
voilà quoi on est pas d'accord sur les
explications pas du tout alors autant
vous raconter avec honnêteté j'en suis
sûr une belle aventure humaine mais moi
ce qui me gêne c'est la mise en scène à
des fins commerciales vous avez prononcé
le mot business de cette aventure
humaine qui aurait pu rester discrète
c'est à dire c'est utilisés
commercialement la détresse des gens la
colère des gens ça ça me gêne vraiment
c'est à dire que je trouve que votre
odyssée humaine elle devient maintenant
un manque de sincérité criant voilà on
n'est pas du tout du tout alors gilles
il ya quand même un point qu'on avait
pas hier vous l'avez la bêtise vous
voulez peut-être salariés les personnes
qui sont là mais totalement bassin pas
les personnes c'est déjà tout le monde
est salarié et mais c'est ce sdf sera
salariés donc ça c'est bien beau coup
l'on savait pas hier voilà bertrand que
tu en penses toi
bon médaille
ce que bertrand sera dans tpm pétition
lundi je pense que la grèce allait une
très belle machine
parce que c'est d'elle
c'est bon bah on va pas faire deux
heures 28 jours et guillaume evin
détiendront choqué par cette image sont
des gros ringard en fait on croit
souvent aux boîtes de nuit des lieux
superficielle non essentiels comme on
l'a entendu pendant le covin là pour moi
il ya une vraie démarche artistique et
sociale en fait monsieur il a pris
toutes les problématiques du moment et
la pauvreté il a pris le chemin que vous
avez des serveur en gilet jaune aussi
voilà ça dénonce en plus il vient en
aide à des gens qui sont socialement
difficulté donc franchement j y étais un
gros ringard et retourne au macumba
système à
kouba et c'est vrai pour gilles du
tournage il danse très bien on l'a
encore vu oui très vite non juste à dire
idriss koudouss a le le truc c'est la
soupe à gries ainsi au grand sport
raymond m'appelait antoine sinon c'est
que les démarches elle est très très
belle tant que vous la raconter mais
nous on la connaît pas on sait pas qui
adf que vous les salariés tout doux tout
ce qu'on voit c'est quelqu'un qui veut
faire du buzz il a misé qui se sert de
sdf et de panneaux de sdf pour qu'on
parle de lui et la preuve on a parlé de
vous que votre boîte mais justement dos
quand c'est sincère une démarche bas
pour l'expliquer parce que si longtemps
c'est moi ça pas tolérer en 24 heures on
n'a pas le temps de l'expliquer mais
j'arrivais sens et on est ouverts ya 48
heures vous avez réussi à placer deux
noms d'autres restent aux femmes achats
alors ces trois ans qu'il veut mais
c'est pas le contraire mais si on ne
boit pas de trois ans et tous ces
rumeurs d'un pub